all right here all yes should be
interesting
Oh another beautiful bag down oh yeah go
go go yeah go come on come on get in get
in good how much gas you got not enough
we'll probably die on the way down
[Music]
you
[Music]
doing good huh it's a beautiful day in
the neighborhood maybe some hydrogen
stuff some most likely Noah bothers in
the event that oh by the way like can't
use any of this back to the place where
we shot some Beast simulator video
there's a radio tower area Hey look we
just got to be prepared and awareness
for what could be up there I mean yes
there's the potential for a mountain
lion but listen let's see we do palm the
top mountain lion everyone act pretty
actually act really big and they're
really loud noises ah
Carmichael grab the camera keep filming
no matter what your get the close-up
doggie he's got a hit get the eyes wait
so here we are at the top of mountain
disappointment literally that's what's
called because apparently when the first
people came up here they thought it was
the highest peak in the LA basin and
they found out that it wasn't hence the
name mount disappointment motion ah the
floor it is immortal go up to that sort
of first press we're gonna hike up there
yep what you're afraid of a hike we're
almost we're like almost out of gas I
felt it go
and then The Gaslight flipped on so
hopefully that was a temporary thing and
we can have enough to get back down the
hill possible we run out of gas
hey we'll be fine just nice and easy
yeah it's pretty pretty serious downturn
gonna go down first yeah and then uh
then it seems like you woke up there
unless you can go around with I hope I'm
not out of gas
yeah worst case scenario we have to hike
down to Jan's car and then drive down to
the bottom of the to where there's a gas
station the big the issue is I was
originally going to go fix my brakes
today so I think between both of us we
have one worker yeah yeah
you know be sweet Carmichael's have been
a drone right now like this that way we
don't because we met Karen it almost
looks like sitting yeah
[Music]
and I robbed
right now
cool I like it take it no so far my
favorite part of the day was talking
about mountain lions so we shot out
cotys um my [ __ ] don't feel much it
we just shout out Cochise flash back and
we got some really great shots I can't
wait to see what Ben does with it truck
in that thing yeah
oh dude ever since I got that roof rack
no looking back
yeah Radek life did I learn anything
we're getting camo that's true guys with
long hair look good in camera um I
learned that I actually vehemently enjoy
saying um like I go out of my way to get
a good no come on come on get in get in
good pop it in Ursula so we're gonna be
player
you're neutral yeah
you get an insert on the gas meter
not a lot to work with point is not to
hit the gas let's
not to the gasp oh no I haven't touched
it since we got onto this road
let me down
don't let me down
don't let me down
on the first time
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
let me down bob ross bob ross the spirit
is everywhere right here you can be on e
for a very very very long time I know
you just keep going just kind of get
there yes I think they are they they
knew that Americans would just run [ __ ]
on drive on the highway to the
dangerzone they're gonna take a ride to
the gas engines burn or there was a man
who knew the way there was a man but a
legend
his soul in his heart he knew the artist
must be true but the legend of the tank
was way past you faster yeah well you
think you'll be just fine without gas
but you're mine
I am chevron corporation operation well
Elon Musk thinks he'll win in this
battle to get without sin but the legend
of the gas was way hard cool well this
if it does go we can push it from here
315
[ __ ] go go go go you got that oh no no
you heard that it might die as we sit
that will not it will not die so we're
at a red light
yes sir and the gas station is right
there right yeah there's this one - go
go go there's another gas station right
here
come on and we ready
[Music]
right it's that time of the month and we
would like to thank some of our most
special patrons on patreon huge shout
out to a friend Calvin Kingdom Andrew
Ryan James Bailey John Welch
Adam J Tilly Silva apply also known as
so is hero Richard Blackburn guys thank
you so much for your support it means a
lot to us especially now that we have
not much to hold on to anymore
[Music]
[Music]